is the wee one strapped in with a safety
belt of some kind does the floaty pod
dock in somehow how do we know baby oats
is in there safely i have no idea if he
wants to eat it or hang it on his wall
are there no other options what if he
wanted to raise it to be his green sun
or what if he wanted to study it it's
not a toy despite one fiscal yoda
working his way into our hearts i must
stay vigilant and remind you that the
sin here is and always will be kids
well yes this pick up the kid by the
scruff like an animal moment serves as a
way to gauge mando's eventual care of
the child and the way he holds him
differently by the end of the episode
it's still a horrible way to pick up a
tiny kid i mean what is the point of
this arch is it for show do people just
walk under it because they can obviously
don't need to and it doesn't look secure
show reenacts my experience after eating
baked goods at coachella easy with that
you take it easy mando doesn't respond
with stop copying me amanda's best guard
boner is so powerful that he completely
forgets that he kidnapped a child such a
large bounty for such a small package
such a non thing to say when he's about
to get snippy when mando asks a question
don't start small talk if you don't want
small talk unfortunately finding a
mandalorian in these trying times
is more difficult
than finding the steel i find this
really hard to believe industrial walks
back to the mandalorian den and reapers
with super fancy armor anyone paying
attention would be able to make the
assumption that there are other
mandalorians not only out there but
nearby
[Music]
since the other mandalorians can't go
out and play the writers have them all
just milling about and fiddling with
their armor instead of enriching
themselves with a game of strategy like
risk or past the pigs
these envious mandalorians showing up to
the yard at the first hint of mando's
milkshake i mean best car how can one be
a coward if one chooses this way of life
so true imagine choosing a life where
you can only use 10 of your field of
vision by choice truly badass stop
trying to convince me otherwise yes i
know some say it's ridiculous and should
[ __ ] any battle advantage but stop it
it means they're brave this is the way
but forget understanding any of the ways
that the way is the way i know i'm
supposed to watch and enjoy and turn off
my questioning mind but i really wish i
understood their code better is it the
same as the guild code that mando breaks
to steal the kid in a moment why are
there no apparent consequences for a
fellow lorian when he tries to rip off
mando's helmet how do you choose the
various options of armor add-ons and is
there a build your armor character
creation screen
since you forego a signet
i shall use the excess to forge
whistling birds then honestly why would
anyone opt in for a segment when a sweet
sweet weapon like whistling birds is a
this is choice way
this is the way this is the way one
would expect this hammer banging
flashbacks position to provide some
armor explanations instead we get some
backstory delivered completely out of
context do you think it's a requirement
to have a flashback to war trauma while
the armor is cooked and if so why would
anyone sit through this
i mean why not get in and hide with your
kid
but
but how did the robot without little
digits on his hand actually open the
door
you had your shot dust breather but you
failed that's respiracist
using this walking into a saloon trope
to remind us that this show isn't
drawing inspiration from the wild west
so much as it's drawing inspiration from
stereotypical movies about the wild west
well we all love amanda's new shiny
metal ass walking in with your best car
hanging out is about as subtle as a
tesla cyber truck and this level of
bling seems to betray mando's generally
stoic demeanor take some time off
enjoy yourself pursuing you know when
someone needs time off which is
especially concerning when you can't
even read the person's expression to
understand their state of mind you're
talking to a wall of armor stop telling
it what to do also considering grief
just told mando that the entire place
hates his guts why would mando want to
stick around mando doesn't finish
threading his shift knob onto the shaft
acting as if you can do anything
covertly when you've got this much shine
staring at your dead comrade long enough
to become dead yourself glad to see
we're still sticking with shooting the
control panel not only disables the lock
but also opens the door cliches the
medical guy looks up and sees the man
who has now removed baby greens from the
medical device i will never understand
the level of confidence needed to do
this without fear of harming the little
one even more you don't yank people off
hospital beds amanda's going back
through this facility the long way if
the room he needed to get to is right by
the outer wall why not blast puck
through this outer wall in gtfo i can
see how mando's helmet wasn't a
disadvantage in this situation because
every one of these idiots has one on but
the cape and sniper rifle on his back
should have been detrimental during
these close quarters fights kind of
example is this set for the kids i guess
suddenly no one in the bad guy block
seems to care about the kids surviving
any longer do the stormtroopers know
they're terrible at aiming so they shoot
badly but confidently therefore avoiding
killing the child but also appearing as
though they're defending their hideout
we now know that these whistling birds
are rare but why are they rare when they
[ __ ] rule if it's about the rarity of
the metal why not find a way to make
them with other metals and if they are
so rare why have an entire gauntlet
designed to contain them only once every
so often oddly none of the explosions in
gunfire brought any curious onlookers to
the building earlier it was said that
everyone had a tracking fob for the
bounty on my yoda from another mother
but they all kept the tracking fobs even
after they found out mando had already
collected the bounty sure some people
are slow to throw things out but the
show wants us to believe that every last
one of these ultra absorbent [ __ ]
kept the thing and that it's still
active after the bounty was completed
because i'm your only hope this just
seems like a weird time for a call back
to princess leia's message to obi-wan or
is it not weird and the two moments are
somehow connected well either way i was
enjoying the show before that line and
now instead of enjoying the show i'm
thinking about possible reasons why
grief kargas being a fanboy right now
[Music]
child endangerment turning and running
away in shame after realizing you
brought an axe to a blaster fight
backseat drivers exposing your tooting
fork amanda should know that when you
realize your blasters and drop to you
while the rest of the firefight is in
standard tuning just take those shots a
full step higher and get through it
that's one impressive weapon a gun that
vapes people yeah seems that the bullets
for this weapon should be rarer than
whistling birds but no
and an interesting attempt to jump from
the dc eu to the mcu it looks like
mantis accidentally landed in the star
wars canon did all the bando people get
the same ping message about mando's
sudden decision to go back on his bounty
and take the kid how did they know to
show up okay disney take all of my money
all of it you're going to have to
relocate the covert telling someone the
reason why they shouldn't be helping you
while they are helping you also i'm
pretty confident the whole mandalorian
group would have had a hard time hiding
anyway ximena got paid in best car
walked it through the street and
sauntered into their covert without any
attempt at being sneaky so anyone could
go down the stairs and peek at the
people wow grief boldly enters the ship
with a gun name directly amando yet
somehow misses him even though he's now
a slightly obscured shiny big guy
standing in steam imagine being this
horrible at aiming and choosing to face
off with mando one on one idiot speaking
of steam there's a button on the ship
that makes it pour out like this for why
oh good grief karga didn't die because
of his best car plot armor
i gotta get one of those why it's not
like you're gonna use it properly
[Music]
giving a metal ball to a child
i have thought my way here to the castle
beyond the goblin city
to take back the child that you have
stolen
welcome to space the infinite frontier
we've got a great show lined up for you
such a large bounty
for such a small package
size snack
have you ever removed your helmet
well actually
that's none of your business christy
this is the way
this is the way
this is the way
are you sure
no matter what
you got
[Music]
how do i look like a hood ornament how
do i know i can trust you
because we got more flows than obi-wan
kenobi ohio dallas